we've heard screenwriters use this
phrase cracking the story so what does
that mean exactly cracking the story is
is it's kind of to continue what we're
talking just talking about it's you have
a store you have the beginnings of a
story but then you're beat you beat at
the store you create the whole story you
roll out the carpet basically the whole
story so you don't really crack the
story and it may be more of a TV term
than a film term I'm not sure but but
you don't crack the story until you are
able to you know sort of you can tell
the story from start to finish and any
of the holes in it are filled and that's
my interpretation of it I mean you know
that you just you know or you know the
concept of cracking something is like oh
that was what was missing we got it now
we crack the story and the rest of it
just falls into place but so there's
that but also I think the concept of
just being able to tell the story from
start to finish if I have to look if I
send in a pitch let's say I write up a
pitch to send into you know a producer a
network or something for for a movie or
a TV pilot or something
I don't just I may send a premise line
and see if just the general premise line
is of interest and they may say oh no
we're doing something like that oh
that's great give me more I will give
them the story from start to finish
doesn't have to be very long it could be
a page and a half that I'm writing but
at least I'm not just giving them
preamble I'm not just giving them the
first act of something I'm not just
giving them you know like a tease I'm
basically telling them where that
cracking that story for them I'm telling
them where that could move for that
story is gonna go from start to finish
not necessarily in great detail
sometimes in more detail but it's really
about being able to show that this is an
entire story this is where this will
move and then we can fill it in and you
know and amplify it as we go along so
it's it's really being able to tell the
story from start to finish for me anyway
that's my interpretation of it so what
about those writers who say sometimes
they begin something without knowing the
ending yeah well I've done that oh you
have I've done that you know or the
ending has changed a lot you know with
again with April May and June that this
play I didn't know I didn't know what
they were gonna find I didn't know that
in the at the end of the first act they
were gonna find the sisters were gonna
find something that just it became the
obvious it became the thing that was
driving me I don't even
realize it and I didn't know what that
thing was gonna be until I thought about
it so yeah that was a case where I
really really didn't know I've
definitely written things where you know
you'd if you're writing a romantic
comedy generally the couple will get
back together in the end you know
there's all of that there's some you
know kind of some Givens but yeah
sometimes you don't know frankly I do
think it's better better to know or at
least have some idea it's like getting
in your car and saying well I know how
to get halfway there but like I don't
really know where I'm going after that
you know it you're gonna be stuck in the
middle of nowhere so it's not dissimilar
with a with a story I I prefer to know
where I was going and I think you know
certainly you know before you start
writing and sitting down and writing it
you should have a pretty good idea of
where you're going and if it does evolve
or it makes ever changes along the way
great you know work with it see where it
takes you you know it these stories
unfold on their own sometimes they you
know but I think it's helpful to like I
said a big believer in structure but I
have and and you know having the beats
out before I start writing something you
know from start to finish but we can be
surprised and I bet there's definitely
been times that I have not known exactly
where I was going until I got there
you